فمع التواصل استهداف روسيا لمنشات الطاقه
باوكرانيا بدا المسؤولون في العاصمه
بالتخطيط الاحتمال غير مسبوق هو اخلاء
سكان المدينه بالكامل في حال حدوث انقطاع
كل للتيار الكهربائي وفقا لصحيفه نيوز
تايمز فقد تعرضت 40% من البنى التحتيه
للطاقه في اوكرانيا للدمار نتيجه القذف
الروسيه الواسع واذا استمرت روسيا في مثل
هذه الهجمات فمن الممكن ان تفقدك اياه
النظام الكهرباء وبالكامل طبعا في هذا
السياق افاد مدير الامن في حكومه بلديتك
افاد انه سيتلقى انذارا بان شبكه على وشكل
انهيار قبل حدوث ذلك باثنتي 10 ساعه على
الاقل مضيفا ان الاخلاق في هذا الحال
سيكون ملزما بسبب توقف الخدمات التي تعتمد
على الكهرباء في المدينه مثل الماء ونتحدث
ايضا عن الصرف الصحي
تمشي
صوتين اعدائنا يبذلون قصار جهدهم لكي تكون
المدينه من دون تدفئه وكهرباء وامدادات
المياه وبشكل عام يريدون منا جميعا ان
نموت هذه هي مهمتهم يعتمد هذا على مدى
قدرتنا على الصمود وعلى مدى استعدادنا
لسنر يوهات مختلفه يعتمد مستقبل بلدنا
ومستقبل كل مواطن على مستوى الاستعداد لذا
يجب ان نكون مستعدين